اعلنت كتائب حزب الله العراقيه تعليق
عملياتها ضد القوات الامريكيه وقالت ان
سبب قرارها هو عدم احراج الحكومه العراقيه
واضافت انها اتخذت قرارها بدعم المظلومين
في غزه بارادتها ودون اي تدخل من الاخرين
مشدده على ان الاطراف الاخرى في محور
المقاومه لا سما ايران لا يعلمون تفاصيل
عملياتها وانهم اعترضوا في كثير من
الاحيان على صعيد كتائب حزب الله العراقيه
ضد القوات
الامريكيه ينضم الينا من بغداد مراس جزيره
عامر لافي عامر كيف يتفاعل موضوع اعلان
كتائب حزب الله العراقيه تعليق عملياتها
ضد القوات الامريكيه وماذا في تفاصيل ما
اعلنه حزب الله
العراقي نعم فدا يعني الى الان لم يصدر اي
شيء عن الحكومه كار ده فعل عن هذا القرار
الذي اتخذه حزب الله العراقي لكن ربما في
المضمون قد يريح الحكومه على اعتبار
لاحظتم في البيان ان السبب الرئيسي لاتخاذ
هذا القرار هو دفع الحرج عن الحكومه لماذا
دفع الحرج عن الحكومه فداء لان